i want to talk about the medical
profession
because here in you know lie the
greatest irony these people who are
dispatched with you know tending to our
health
have this you know complete myopic
perspective when it comes to
prioritizing sleep in their own
profession and there's this
systemic you know kind of infrastructure
setup
that prioritizes lack of sleep these
residents who have to work these 30-hour
shifts
this legacy of an old tradition that was
set in stone
long ago and continues like unbelievably
to
you know be the standard operating
procedure today which is unbelievable
and i loved how you told the history of
this
this guy halstead right yeah who who
basically was a hard ass back in the
at the turn of the century and just said
this is the way we're going to do it
and today we still do it in the manner
that
that that he kind of established back
then but it turns out he was like a
raging cocaine addict
that's right yeah so william halstead
was the guy who set up the uh the
resident
the first resident uh training program
in the united states
um at johns hopkins university um and
you know it's called a residency for a
reason because you're going to become a
resident
you're going to live in the hospital
right and
he was known for being able to go these
heroic long stretches without
needing sleep people were stunned and he
expected his junior residents
to match him in that and
gradually after his death it emerged the
reason why he was
able to do that hosted in his early
career was actually studying
um the anesthetic properties
of cocaine and
unfortunately he started to use cocaine
himself
and he become he became uh an accidental
addict and that was how he was able to
just go
days straight right without seemingly
you know
needing sleep so apparently set the
expectation
that everybody else should be able to
should match the way that he was
to go the same degree now there were
times there were stories where
people would say you know he would in
the operating theater
he would have to go and take a break
because he was saying he was not feeling
well he was sweating a lot he
seemed to be cold and he would have to
go take a break and you know his because
he was
detoxing during the long uh surgery so
he had to go and administer again
um and there were even stories so
he knew that he was an addict and he
sought
to go into rehab under a different uh
surname
and at the time they were treating
cocaine addiction
with morphine right and unfortunately
what happened is that he came out of
that rehabilitation program with
no resolution to his cocaine addiction
but now he had a heroin addiction right
and the story goes that he would you
know have his
shirts his white shirts sent away to get
laundered in places like
paris you know friend and they would
come back both white and starchy but
there would also be other
you know white related compounds
in there so and we've never let go of
that
you know arcane and i think inane
practice
and it's not medical residents who are
at fault here
you know speak to any of them and none
of them will tell you that
that's what i want to be doing yeah um
you know and i i've
had conversations with a dear friend
called peter tier who is
who went through the medical practice
his wonderful medical doctor
and he describes you know some shocking
history with
a lack of sleep and the statistics are
just damning firstly what we know is
that medical residents
who have performed a 30-hour shift will
make 460 percent more diagnostic errors
in the intensive care unit
secondly we know that if you're going to
have elective surgery let's say
and your surgeon has slept less than six
hours
in the previous 24 they're 170 percent
more likely
to cause a major surgical error such as
rupturing a blood vessel or
you know damaging or puncturing an organ
then the irony is that a medical
resident who's worked a 30-hour shift
when they get back in their car to drive
home at the end of their shift
they're 168 more likely to get into a
car crash
now returning to the accident and
emergency room
from which they probably came but now as
a patient
rather than a doctor and
you know i've tried with many other
people to lobby the medical institute um
and or institution and try to understand
why
why is this the case and i think some of
it has to do with the old boys network
that it's almost like a hazing that you
know we went through it
so you have to do it you know you know
man up suit up boot up woman up
you know you you need to get through
this this is a rites of passage
and again it comes back to that idea
that thinking that you can fight
mother nature and evolution is just
thick headed and that's what this just
yeah i mean i get the idea
that you have to develop a level of
rigor and
emotional resiliency to handle that kind
of job and there is something to be said
for
you know putting people in challenging
situations to see how they
uh function under high stress but the
sleep deprivation aspect of it is just
ridiculous you know if if when you
go through medical school you know you
take an oath which is to do no harm
and then you're placed under conditions
of insufficient sleep that statistically
will guarantee that you will do more
harm than if you were sleeping
or working let's say just a 16-hour
shift yeah you know and one of the push
i think some of the pushback that you
receive or i've received
is look my mind's made up don't confuse
me with the data
right and you think okay you're the
doctor
you're the scientist what can i do you
know
isn't this self-evident and one of the
arguments though i think that has some
legitimacy
is that of continuity of care that if
you
are flip-flopping back and forth between
a resident every six hours
the continuity of the patient care can
decrease but then i i thought about that
argument for a long time and then i
looked at
um a number of medical uh country or
sorry the medical systems throughout the
world
and i asked how long does it take to
train their residents and how good
is their medical care and what i found
is that there are places like new
zealand
uh france switzerland they all have
their residents working
no more than 16 hours and
their quality of health care is actually
ranks far
better in the worldwide statistics than
the united states
so you can't tell me that you can't
train an individual within
five years or less at a reasonable
amount of sleep and not maintain high
quality of medical practice right
well part of the problem tracks back to
the fact that there's no
education on this in medical school
right so these doctors who then become
hospital administrators
don't have the proper background to make
a better decision about this
that's exactly right so i also you know
myself and some other researchers
you look at the medical curriculum
throughout many of these
world first world nations and what you
discover is that
on average the average medical resident
will receive somewhere between an
hour and a half to two hours of
education on sleep
relative to the entire medical program
now that strikes me because
that's one-third of their patients lives
and that one-third of their life spent
asleep makes a profound difference to
the two-thirds of waking
health life why aren't we investing more
in the education of sleep for our
medical residents
well why aren't we have you seen since
the book came out and you've been
you know speaking regularly on this
have you seen changes positive movement
in this regard a little but not not too
much
yeah unfortunately i think there are
some medical programs around this
country at least that are doing better
than
others there's a quite a variability
so some are prioritizing it and
understanding its importance
but overall no i think that that same
sort of some of that hubris
is still present um what do we do to
change that
well you know i tried early on speaking
about this from the statistics of
the patients from a point of view of
compassion and empathy for
our young residents and that sort of
just
falls on deaf ears what i realized is
that you have to speak in a currency
with which
you know medical institutions and
administrators will listen to which is
dollars and cents
and when you start to rack up the
numbers regarding malpractice suits
caused by insufficiency
start paying attention start paying
attention yeah so i was just stupid i
i i thought about appealing in the wrong
language
[Music]
you